on va commencer cette audition parce que
nous avons nous avons des délais
contraints et madame la Présidente
également des délais contrats je
voudrais la remercier parce que je
voulais absolument qu'on fasse cette
audition avant la coupure de la session
et les agendas des uns et des autres
étaient compliqués à mettre en phase
donc nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
aujourd'hui madame la Présidente de la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
que nous connaissons bien dans cette
commission pour d'autres raisons pour
échanger avec elle sur l'actualité de la
régulation des marchés de l'électricité
et du gaz c'est une actualité qui est
riche en France avec ces derniers jours
l'application d'une pénalité nous venons
d'en parler d'un virgule 6 milliards au
fournisseurs alternatifs dans le cadre
de la reine ou la substitution d'un prix
de référence au tarif réglementé de
vente du gaz ou encore la préparation de
la future loi quinquennale sur l'énergie
de programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie c'est aussi une actualité qui
est riche en Europe avec depuis quelques
mois les négociations en cours sur la
réforme du marché européen de
l'électricité ou le paquet justement à
l'objectif 55 que nous connaissons bien
notre commission et son groupe d'études
énergies sont présidents Daniel
grimilliat étant bien sûr là sont très
mobilisés sur le sujet depuis de
nombreux mois nos collègues Dominique
Estrosi ça sonne et Fabien gay ont juste
rendu leur conclusion de la mission
d'information c'est les conditions
d'utilisation à la reine juste avant
votre audition le rapport a été madame
la Présidente voter à l'unanimité de
tous les groupes de plus notre collègue
Daniel grimillet président du groupe
d'études énergie a fait adopter deux
propositions de résolution européenne
sur la réforme du marché de
l'électricité la première c'est les
pouvoirs des autorités de régulation la
seconde sur les outils de financement et
de protection enfin nous avons beaucoup
légiféré cette année avec la loi
d'accélération sur les énergies
renouvelables qui avaient été confiées à
notre collègue Patrick Chauvet ici
présent et celle de une accélération sur
l'énergie nucléaire dont notre collègue
Daniel grimillet avait eu aussi la
charge et donc il vous interrogeront
quant à moi je souhaiterais vous poser
deux questions introductives sur la
protection des consommateurs tout
d'abord quelle appréciation portez-vous
sur le bouclier tarifaire et la reine
plus ont-ils vraiment permis de protéger
les consommateurs résidentiels au tarif
réglementés de vente d'électricité dans
le premier cas et les autres
consommateurs résidentiels et
professionnels dans le second cas le
coût du bouclier tarifaire 45 milliards
d'euros selon l'état et du relèvement de
la reine de 8 milliards comme nous
venons le de le voir sont-ils justifiés
plus encore quel jugement portez-vous
sur l'extinction des tarifs réglementés
de vente du gaz comment s'effectue la
sortie de ces tarifs qui ont concerné 3
millions de clients résidentiels
c'est-à-dire 7 et demi pour cent notre
consommation de gaz en 2021 la creux le
Médiateur de l'énergie ont-ils organisé
une campagne d'information du quand on
publie comme le prévoit l'article 63 de
la loi énergique climat de 2019 et le
futur dispositif de prix de référence
est-il suffisant pour protéger les
consommateurs de la flambée du prix du
gaz voilà les questions que je voulais
vous adresser avant votre propos
liminaire et ensuite je passerai la
parole d'abord à nos collègues Daniel
gremière Patrick Chauvet et puis Fabien
Gall Dominique Estrosi ça sonne voilà
madame la Présidente et le tout doit
être terminé vers 50 si j'ai bien
compris 11h50 45 dans un monde idéal
50 dans le monde du Sénat voilà
je suis à disposition du Sénat madame la
Présidente vous le savez donc madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
merci de me donner l'opportunité de
cette audition vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente nous avons eu des relations
approfondie et au titre de la présidence
de la Creuse je tiens vraiment à
maintenir des relations de proximité
avec l'Assemblée et le Sénat ça me
paraît extrêmement important vous avez
aujourd'hui en primeur notre rapport
d'activité 2022 nous on l'a pas encore
eu au bureau il nous a pas encore été
livrés donc vous avez vraiment les
premiers exemplaires voilà donc je
repars avec et ça vous donnera les
éléments de la base de ce que nous avons
fait l'année dernière je pense que c'est
un document qui peut être éclairant pour
vos travaux
au-delà nous sommes très mobilisés
actuellement sur la préparation
des éléments qui permettront le de
soumettre au vote la prochaine loi de
programmation énergique climat et des
textes réglementaires qui vont avec la
programmation pluriane de l'énergie et
la SNPC notamment avec trois grands
objectifs qui sont de mon point de vue
les trois grands enjeux des années qui
viennent le premier c'est engagé le pays
vers la neutralité carbone en 2050 donc
la transition écologique mais surtout de
franchir un palier qui sera difficile à
franchir autour des années 2030 à 2035
le deuxième c'est renforcer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement c'est un sujet qu'on
a vu apparaître au moment de la crise
avec la guerre en Ukraine et qui en fait
est absolument clé et sur lequel nous
avons encore des défis et le troisième
c'est de permettre à tous les
consommateurs les particuliers les
entreprises des industriels de
bénéficier d'une énergie à la fois
suffisamment abondante à des prix
raisonnables qui permettent de maintenir
le pouvoir d'achat d'un côté et la
compétitivité de l'autre ce sont trois
objectifs
ambitieux mes trois objectifs à
atteindre sur la production des
carbonées et le mix énergétique
quelques mots on a maintenant grâce à
RTE que vous auditionnez je crois soit
avant l'été soit après
des éléments sur la trajectoire
énergétique qui qui montre l'ambition et
les palliée à atteindre dans la
précédente PPE les hypothèses étaient
des hypothèses de stabilité du besoin
d'électricité et donc les questions se
concentraient sur la répartition à
l'intérieur d'un besoin et d'une
production stable du mix électrique on
en est plus du tout là à chaque fois
carpe fait des prévisions et les
actualités RTE augmente encore le besoin
d'électricité du pays on est à 460
terawh aujourd'hui et on parle de 800
terawatts en 2050 avec une première une
étape qui pourrait être à 650
terawattheure dès 2035 pour le seul
secteur industriel on passerait de 120 à
180 terawattheure d'électricité donc nos
besoins électriques sont considérables
et l'enjeu va être vraiment d'avoir un
système de production et de distribution
et de transport et de réseau qui
répondent à ça en termes de production
ça veut dire du point de vue de la crue
développer à la fois le nucléaire et les
EnR la creux est peu compétente sur le
développement des infrastructures
nucléaires même si à travers la
tarification en a évidemment un rôle sur
les EnR on est l'un des acteurs puisque
nous opérons les appels d'offres pour le
compte du gouvernement et donc nous
serons un des acteurs de l'ambition de
plus 40 gigawh de puissance sur l'éolien
offshore du développement
maîtriser de l'éolien terrestre et du
développement du photovoltaïque tout
type de photovoltaïques que ce soit sur
toiture ou au sol avec bien sûr les
préoccupations de non-artificialisation
et de
et de développement d'un agréé voltaïsme
qui permette de protéger aussi notre
modèle agricole nous sommes évidemment à
la fois volontariste et un peu inquiet
volontariste en accompagnant tous ces
appels d'offres et en travaillant très
précisément avec le gouvernement sur les
modalités des appels d'offres des
guichets tarifaires et inquiets parce
qu'il faut vraiment qu'on accélère on
n'y est pas encore
la volonté est là la question de
l'acceptabilité se pose évidemment vous
vous connaissez ça très bien il faut
qu'on arrive à trouver les moyens de
développer à la bonne vitesse le PV le
solaire et l'éolien en particulier
sur le mix énergétique
la deuxième question c'est la
complémentarité des énergies pour nous
elle est essentielle nous sommes le
régulateur non seulement de
l'électricité mais aussi du gaz demain
peut-être de l'hydrogène de la capture
du carbone on a besoin de toutes les
sources d'énergie on a besoin
d'électricité on a besoin de gaz de plus
en plus dégâts décarbonées mais pour
l'instant on ne tient pas notre
équilibre énergétique sans gaz on a
besoin de réseau de chaleur aussi et
probablement avec un travail de grande
proximité à faire sur la complémentarité
gaz et réseaux de chaleur qu'on pourrait
développer encore on l'a assez largement
mis en évidence dans le rapport qu'on a
publié récemment sur les infrastructures
gazières
le gaz à vocation est totalement
décarboné le facteur limitant va être
notre capacité à produire du gaz vert
sur le territoire français avec de la
méthanisation et potentiellement
d'autres procédés de production mais qui
eux-mêmes nécessitent soit de
l'électricité pour faire de l'hydrogène
pour ensuite pouvoir faire de la
méta-nation voilà soit d'autres types de
techniques dans les hypothèses les plus
élevés de production de biogaz on vend
de gaz de synthèse vert on est à peu
près à la moitié de la consommation
actuelle en 2050 ce qui veut dire de
toute façon une division par deux de
notre consommation de gaz pour être
atteindre notre objectif de tes
carbonations complets en 2050 ce qui
veut dire une évolution des usages du
point de vue de la crue une évolution
maîtrisée et maîtriser dans la durée des
usages parce qu'on ne sait pas reporter
brutalement les usages de gaz vers les
usages de l'électricité pour des
questions de gestion de la pointe et des
questions de réseau
ça m'amène au point sur les réseaux ça
va vite potentiellement devenir le
facteur bloquant de toute la transition
écologique donc les réseaux c'est le
cœur du métier de la Creuse puisque la
creux était créée pour ça à la base un
régulateur des réseaux nous démarrons
enfin nous sommes on fait plus que
démarrer nous sommes en plein boom de la
négociation des tarifs de réseaux
gaziers pour les quatre prochaines
années
nous ferons les tarifs des réseaux
électriques l'année prochaine les enjeux
sont pas du tout les mêmes en
électricité la question c'est
d'accompagner aussi vite que possible le
développement des investissements
investissement qui doivent couvrir les
raccordements à la fois raccordement des
très grosses installations de type
éolien offshore mais aussi des
installations toutes petites de
production d'énergie renouvelables des
carbonées sur
les investissements sont considérables
on va passer de 1 et demi milliards
d'euros par an à 2,5 et on va passer de
4 à plus de 5 milliards d'euros par an
pour enedis donc il faut que les tarifs
soient en capacité d'absorber ses
besoins d'investissement complémentaires
et puis on a une question de délai de
faisabilité donc de filières
industrielle pour être capable
d'accompagner la filière réseau on a
aussi du renouvellement à faire des
interconnexions à faire donc en
électricité on a un développement massif
devant nous
en gaz on est dans une situation
différente avec un effet ciseaux
c'est-à-dire des infrastructures qu'on
va garder jusqu'à 2050 dans la très
grande majorité des infrastructures et
une consommation qui va baisser donc un
tarif unitaire qui mécaniquement
augmente si vous avez les mêmes coûts à
répartir sur moins de consommation et
donc des enjeux de d'évolution de
régulation tarifaire important qu'il
faut qu'on démarre maintenant pour que
cet effet ciseaux soit à peu près
acceptable et supportable par les
consommateurs
je voudrais insister dans ce point là
sur la flexibilité c'est à dire que en
électricité en particulier une partie de
la réponse est dans le développement des
réseaux une autre partie de la réponse
est vraiment dans le développement des
moyens de flexibilité tout type de
flexibilité le stockage que ce soit des
batteries ou des Flex l'effacement le
déplacement de la consommation la
réduction de la consommation à la pointe
et bien sûr la sobriété donc la creux a
fait de la sobriété un de ses axes
d'action ce qui est assez nouveau
puisque on est indirectement concerné
par la sobriété mais dans les
incitations tarifaires on peut
travailler sur la sobriété et on va
continuer à soutenir tous les moyens de
flexibilité parce que on ne saura pas
faire simplement physiquement en
développement de réseaux si on associe
pas ça de la sobriété et à de la
flexibilité
j'en viens peut-être maintenant à la
question du fonctionnement du marché
donc la protection du consommateur est
ça me permettra de répondre à vos
questions madame la Présidente
pour que tout ceci fonctionne il faut
parallèlement que les prix de
l'électricité et du gaz soient
supportable pour à la fois pour nos
concitoyens et pour les entreprises et
les industriels c'est l'enjeu de tout le
travail qui est en cours dans le réforme
européenne du marché de l'énergie enfin
du marché de l'électricité avec la
volonté de faire émerger des prix long
terme sur le marché de gros et que c'est
pris long terme se répercutent sur le
marché de détails donc comme vous le
savez la discussion n'est pas HP à
Bruxelles la présidence suédoise n'a pas
permis d'aboutir donc le sujet est
repris en président espagnol et puis en
parallèle
nous sommes en train de
d'actualiser le rapport que nous avions
produit en 2020-2021 sur le coût complet
du nucléaire pour permettre au
gouvernement français de proposer au
Parlement les modalités de régulation
franco-française du nucléaire en
attendant pour répondre à vos deux
questions
vous le savez c'est pas une surprise et
je suppose qu'on aura une discussion sur
ce sujet du point de vue de la crue la
reine est un mécanisme qui protège
effectivement le consommateur final donc
du point de vue de la creux la reine
n'est pas un mécanisme qui enrichit les
fournisseurs alternatifs et nous
veillons
mais mobilisant tous les outils que nous
avons à notre disposition dans ce que
vous nous avez donné à lutter contre les
éventuels abus et c'est vraiment une
préoccupation importante mais la Reine
permet de vendre pas trop cher
probablement pas assez cher aujourd'hui
puisque les 42 euros ne sont pas voilà
non ne sont pas représentatifs du coup
actuel du nucléaire mais en tout cas
permet de transférer un prix plus bas
aux consommateurs fin donc dans ce cadre
du point de vue de la crue la reine
Prusse la reine plus a contribué à
limiter un peu les prix pas tellement
pour les consommateurs individuels qui
étaient couverts par le bouclier par
ailleurs mais pour les entreprises pour
l'exercice 2022 et en ce qui concerne
bouclier et amortisseurs de mon point de
vue le bouclier à réellement couvert
très efficacement les consommateurs
individuels et tous ceux qui étaient
susceptibles d'être au TRV avec une
dépense budgétaire importante nous on
est en train de réévaluer les charges de
CSPE ont délibère le 13 juillet
l'ordre de grandeur pour 2023 donc les
charges de du bouclier qui vont peser
sur l'exercice budgétaire 2023 soit au
titre de 2023 soit au titre des
rattrapages des années précédentes sont
autour de 30 milliards d'euros c'est
l'ordre de grandeur c'est un
investissement de la nation
effectivement extrêmement important mais
qui a permis de de limiter les hausses à
4% en 2022 et 15% en 2023 ce qui mais
pour le consommateur individuel le prix
de l'électricité parmi les plus bas
d'Europe en France en ce qui concerne
l'extinction des terres végés c'était
aussi une préoccupation très importante
quand je suis arrivée c'est un des
sujets que j'ai souhaité qu'on regarde
le plus près possible il me semble que
l'accompagnement fait par le médiateur
et par nous-mêmes fonctionnent plutôt
bien nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur
beaucoup de points le premier c'est
l'offre passerelle donc vérifiez avec
engie que l'offre par défaut qui est
l'offre dans laquelle bascule les
consommateurs qui n'ont pas choisi de
sortir des terres végés ou en tout cas
qui n'ont pas choisi un nouveau
fournisseur que cette offre est une
offre acceptable et cette offre elle est
très proche des terres végés actuels et
donc on peut dire que les consommateurs
qui passent en offre passerelle seront
dans une situation qui de mon point de
vue est satisfaisante par ailleurs nous
avons cherché à éclairer les
consommateurs pour qu'ils puissent
choisir un fournisseur dans de bonnes
conditions donc au-delà de tous les
courriers formels qui ont été envoyés
par les gestionnaires des tarifs
réglementés conformément à la loi il y a
eu une série de courriers nous avons
décidé de produire un prix repère qui
permet aux consommateurs d'avoir une
idée de où est le marché en choisissant
son fournisseur
les choix de fournisseurs se font plus
ou moins maintenant d'ailleurs moi j'ai
pas de chiffres sur le nombre de
personnes qui ont choisi un fournisseur
récemment je pense qu'on les aura pas
tout de suite on les aura probablement
au deuxième semestre
néanmoins ce prix repère est connu il
est repris par le comparateur du
médiateur avec lequel on travaille
étroitement je pense que ça permet aux
clients de
d'éclairer leur choix de fournisseur
dans une période dans laquelle il faut
que les clients se décident à choisir
désormais un fournisseur je rappelle
quand même que les terres VG fixés par
la creux était fixé à partir d'une
formule de calcul ou 85% du prix était
mensuel il me semble
et le reste trimestriel ce qui veut dire
que ce prix varier tous les mois et que
en 2021 avant bouclier les tarifs
réglementés du gaz pour les particuliers
ont augmenté d'un peu plus de 50% entre
le 1er janvier 2021 et le premier
octobre 2021 donc les terres VG par
eux-mêmes n'étaient pas particulièrement
protecteur par rapport aux variations du
marché puisqu'il reflétaient les
variations du marché les prix
réglementés ont augmenté de 50% en moins
d'un an en 2021 jusqu'à ce que le
gouvernement mette en place un bouclier
tarifaire gaz et donc la mécanique des
trvg qui est une mécanique mensuelle
était en fait peu protectrice des
consommateurs contrairement au trve qui
sont fixés avec une formule différente
qui
qui est fondée sur les prix des deux
années précédentes essentiellement plus
la reine plus les traitements
donc voilà peut-être les points que je
voulais mentionner dans mon introduction
qui doit être un petit peu trop longue
évidemment et je vous remercie et je
prends toutes les questions
on va commencer par Daniel Gremillet
voilà Daniel tu peux poser tes questions
ensuite Patrick Chauvet
oui merci Madame brillante madame la
présente à mon tour je souhaiterais
recueillir votre avis sur deux sujets
d'actualité tout d'abord quel est votre
point de vue sur la réforme du marché
européen d'électricité les nouveaux
outils de financement long terme les CFD
les PPA sont-ils pertinents pensez-vous
qu'un dispositif de CFD puisse se
substituer à la reine après 2025 si oui
dans quelles conditions par ailleurs les
interventions ciblées par dans la
fixation des prix en cas de crise
sont-elles satisfaisantes estimez-vous
leurs critères de mise en oeuvre
initiative de la Commission européenne
d'exigence de hausse de prix ou la
limitation de volume de consommation
suffisamment opérationnelle
plus encore quelle appréciation
portez-vous sur les futurs lois
quinquennales un beau sujet sur
l'énergie et la PPE avez-vous un point
de vue sur le mix énergétique idéal pour
ce qui est du Sénat il s'est positionné
pour un mix majoritairement nucléaire à
l'horizon 2050 ainsi que pour un
couplage de la production nucléaire avec
celle de l'hydrogène
partez partagez vous cette position et
enfin quelle est votre avis sur
l'évolution des charges de services
publics de l'énergie qui sous-tend de
les dispositifs de soutien public aux
énergies renouvelables n'oublions pas
l'automne dernier la creux avait évalué
ses charges à moins à 35 milliards
d'euros compte tenu de la hausse du prix
d'électricité ou en étant et quel sera
leur niveau et l'objectif 2023 et celui
prévisionnel pour les années futures
voilà les petites questions que je
souhaitais complémentaire moi notre
président de vous poser merci les petits
enjeux Patrick
Chauvet qui était le rapporteur de la
loi voilà
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente je souhaiterais vous poser
une question justement sur l'application
de la loi accélération des énergies
renouvelables cette loi a modifié les
critères de sélection des projets
d'énergie ou d'hydrogène renouvelable
soutenu par appel d'offres en leur
appliquant un bilan carbone et une
contribution territoriale cette loi
aussi confortée les attributions de la
creux s'agissant des raccordements dont
la modification de l'ordre de priorité
la mutualisation des travaux de
renforcement ou la révision des schémas
régionaux de raccordement au réseau des
énergies renouvelables cette loi a enfin
élargi les attributions de la creux
concernant les énergies renouvelables
dont le déploiement de l'hydrogène bas
carbone ou renouvelable la surveillance
des contrats de long terme en
électricité et gaz renouvelables ou la
mise en oeuvre d'opérations
d'autoconsommation étendue au gaz
renouvelable je vous remercie de nous
livrer votre avis sur ces novations et
leur application
merci beaucoup Patrick je vais donner
enfin la parole aux deux rapporteurs du
rapport que nous avons
validé ce matin je commencerai par
Fabien gay
bonjour madame la Présidente moi je
voulais vous dire publiquement que tout
d'abord que même si nous avons des
débats je dois avouer que le travail que
vous effectuez depuis un an et d'extrême
qualité
voilà je vous le dis parce que j'étais
pas là l'an dernier à la même époque
chez vous avez eu des débats je sais pas
ce que j'aurais voté mais probablement
que j'aurais voté contre votre
nomination
et si j'avais à voter aujourd'hui je
voudrais pour que vous soyez que vous
continuez non mais je vous le dis parce
que pour avoir des débats mais même si
on a des désaccords je trouve que vous
avez pris les questions en main voilà
non mais je pense que c'est bien aussi
de pouvoir se le dire je vous remercie
beaucoup ça a beaucoup de valeur pour
moi donc je vous remercie non mais je
pense que c'est bien de se le dire
bon on vient de faire un rapport alors
je après j'ai des débats la reine ne
protège absolument pas les consommateurs
je vous dis ça vous savez
puisqu'on a un super rapport avec
Dominique je vais m'en contenter sur le
rapport et pas sur les débats qui nous
animent mais qui vont continuer à nous
animer
vous allez annoncer ou vous avez annoncé
pardonnez-moi une pénalité de 1,6
milliards sur le CPE et 21,9 millions
outils du CP2 avec Dominique nous et
l'ensemble de la commission puisque le
rapport a été adopté
vous le savez on a été assez surpris
dans les auditions que l'ensemble des
des gens auditionnés ne savaient pas où
aller le CPE
voilà et ça quand même qu'on soit pour
ou contre le marché un moment donné il
faut des règles et des règles précises
et pour le coup je trouve un peu bizarre
que lorsqu'on a fraudé où on a abusé on
va dire ça comme ça on met dans un pot
commun et que l'ensemble des gens qui
ont fraudé ou abusé puissent en tirer un
avantage voyez je paye une amende
lorsque je fais un délit je paye une
amende à l'état je paye pas une amende
qui va dans un pot commun ou tous ceux
qui auraient fraudé dans l'année se
verrait attribuer une part c'est
complètement complètement surréaliste
donc est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
une des propositions que nous faisons
après la mise en oeuvre c'est une autre
question mais que cet argent là retourne
au consommateurs et aux consommatrices
qui soient résidentielles n'ont TPE PME
etc et je vous dis moi je conteste j'ai
bien lu les 12 pages je conteste le le
le mode de calcul qui est donc fait que
c'est à partir de 230 euros 232 euros
que vous avez commencé à appliquer le
CPE moi j'ai pas fait beaucoup d'études
de maths mais 70%
de de de l'électricité qui est fournie
et de la reine au prix de 40 euros ça
veut dire que les 30 autres pour cent à
peu près en moyenne si on retire les 230
euros que vous avez
dont vous avez fixé le plafond pour
faire les amandes serait autour de 700
euros alors même s'il y a eu un pic à
1000 euros au coeur du mois d'août 2022
je conteste le fait que les fournisseurs
sur une année et du racheter 30% de
l'électricité à un prix moyen de 700
. donc je pense que les 1 milliard 6
d'amandes enfin de CP1 mais pour que
tout le monde se comprenne d'amende que
vous allez prononcer et vraiment
sous-évaluer et je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus que cela donc on a une
vraie question et puis deuxième chose
pour pas être trop long et rester dans
les clous
tout tout tout on pense qu'il faut et on
vous donne
un certain nombre d'éléments pour
renforcer les sanctions et les contrôles
et notamment sur les abus d'arène et les
comportements opportunistes sur la
question saisonnière qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez voilà et après il y a
Dominique qui va vous vous donner
les les autres recommandations je vous
remercie en tout cas madame la
Présidente merci Fabien Dominique
merci madame la Présidente la Présidente
je voudrais également bien sûr
m'associer aux propos de Fabien en tout
cas lorsqu'on vous a auditionné dans le
cadre cette mission d'information vous
avez bien évidemment été l'une des
premières à être auditionnée vous avez
déjà apporté un certain nombre
d'informations qui nous ont permis
d'aller plus loin dans nos travaux donc
je voudrais compléter par rapport aux
propositions que vous venant de faire
sur notre mission d'information on a une
série de propositions qui concerne aussi
la consolidation des obligations des
fournisseurs on suggère de renforcer des
conditions qui sont requises pour
bénéficier d'une autorisation de de
fournitures avec l'institution
d'obligation prudentielle nous
souhaitons également que puisse être
centralisé ces autorisations de
fourniture auprès de la creux plutôt que
ce que c'est actuellement auprès du
ministère de la transition écologique et
une fois délivré ces autorisations de
fournitures pour nous devrait être mieux
encadrée avec des réexamens mais aussi
des retraits ou des suspensions
effectifs et la quatrième série de
propositions elle a très à
l'amélioration de la protection des
consommateurs parce que là aussi voilà
la finalité c'est que véritablement vous
avez fait référence en disant qu'il
fallait toujours mieux informer les
consommateurs mais nous le proposons
également dans le cadre de cette mission
d'information et de ce point de vue là
nous appelons à modifier l'article
l224-10 du Code de la Consommation qui
autorise aujourd'hui les modifications
contractuelles en allongeant le délai de
prévenance en instituant une information
loyale complète et circonstanciée et en
encadrant les évolutions qui sont liées
aux indexations de prix et nous
proposons aussi de renforcer
l'information des consommateurs sur le
caractère risqué des offres
en cessant d'assimiler à des prix fixes
celles qui font effectivement l'objet
d'un écrêtement d'arène enfin nous
souhaiterions compléter le comparateur
d'offres du Médiateur national de
l'énergie notamment en envisageant
dimensionner les fournisseurs qui ont
fait l'objet de sanctions de la part du
cordiste et selon une logique du Naman
shame
je prendrai ensuite les autres questions
car il y en a d'autres je vais vous
laisser déjà répondre sur ces premiers
éléments merci madame la Présidente et
permet c'était moi de remercier monsieur
le sénateur Fabien gay pour ses propos
introductifs qui me touche beaucoup et
voilà je mets de la volonté et de
l'énergie à conduire cette belle
institution qu'elle a creuse ça me
permet aussi de saluer l'action du
collège du directeur général et des
services de cette institution maintenant
pour répondre à tous les propos monsieur
le sénateur grimille
pour moi la réforme du marché européen
va dans le bon sens parce que elle porte
un élément qui est très important qui
est arrêté de faire en sorte que le prix
de marché final pour le consommateur
soit le prix de court terme on a un
marché de court terme qui fonctionne qui
permet de faire de l'ajustement offre
demande à quelques mois quelques
semaines voire quelques jours mais ça
n'est pas normal que le prix final du
consommateur soit aussi dépendante ce
prix de court terme donc pour ça il faut
faire monter tous les outils de long
terme c'est à dire les un marché plus
liquide avec des échéances à 5 ans des
contrats fordy Friends qui sont des
contrats dans lesquels une contrepartie
en général public
garantit à un prix d'achat et donc de
revente aux producteurs et les pipiers
qui sont des contrats de gré à gré entre
consommateurs final et producteurs qui
sont des contrats privés et c'est
vraiment le développement de ces outils
qui devrait nous permettre de ramener
des prix finaux plus proches du coût de
production et donc plus proche de la
réalité du mix énergétique sur le
territoire national donc pour moi c'est
extrêmement important et ça va avec le
renforcement des obligations
prudentielles des fournisseurs qui est à
la fois un élément très important pour
la protection du consommateur pour
répondre à madame la sénatrice Estrosi
Saône mais aussi parce que si on a des
obligations fournisseurs d'avoir une
partie de leur approvisionnement qui est
à long terme dans ce cas on développe
encore plus le marché long terme et donc
on protège encore plus le consommateur
contre la volatilité des prix le
règlement européen qui est actuellement
sur sur la table va dans cette direction
là et comme vous le savez les
discussions portent beaucoup sur quel
type d'actifs peuvent être sous contrat
fordy friends contrat pour différence et
en particulier les actifs existants et
donc en particulier le nucléaire
français et les discussions ne sont pas
achevées
la régulesse enfin la reine se termine
au 1er janvier 2026 donc de toute façon
il faut penser le Poste à Rennes et ce
poste à Rennes peut être soit avec un
contrat pour différence soit et on y
travaille aussi avec un mécanisme qui
serait plutôt un plafond de prix et qui
permettra EDF de commercialiser en toute
liberté jusqu'à un plafond prix qui
ensuite protégerait le consommateur si
les prix devaient devenir trop élevés
mais que ce soit l'un ou l'autre de
toute façon il faudra un mécanisme qui
prend le relais
sur les critères de mobilisation de
crise tels qui sont aujourd'hui écrit
c'est vraiment pour lutter contre une
éventuelle nouvelle crise telle que
celle qu'on a connu et donc ça n'est pas
applicable en routine sur le marché donc
il faut vraiment qu'on arrive à trouver
les outils de routine sur le marché qui
atteignent cet objectif de développement
des énergies électriques des carbonées
et de protection du consommateur
sur la question que vous posez sur sur
la loi de programmation et la PPE
sur le mix énergétique je sais pas si
c'est vraiment le rôle de la creux
d'avoir complètement une position en
opportunité sur la répartition du mix
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
évidemment on soutien mix des carboné
enfin c'est l'enjeu de la décennie des
50 années qui viennent d'arriver à
décarboner
non seulement notre production
électrique qui l'est déjà très largement
mais aussi notre économie c'est-à-dire
les transports le bâtiment l'industrie
et que au sein d'un mix des carbonés on
a besoin d'une fraction de pilotable
significative parce que ça devient
compliqué de gérer le mix et
d'équilibrer l'offre et la demande
au-delà d'un certain volume de NR alors
quel est le bon chiffre je suis pas sûr
que je me risquerais à à donner une
indication aujourd'hui mais c'est pour
ça qu'on a besoin de nucléaire et
d'hydrol d'Hydro est quand même assez
largement pilotable le nucléaire est une
énergie de base
on peut développer et on doit développer
des ENR classique solaire et éoliens
plus on a des ENR classique plus les
mécanismes de stockage et de flexibilité
sont extrêmement importants parce que
plus les énergies sont intermittentes et
plus il faut trouver une réponse au
décalage entre la production
interminante tente et la consommation à
des moments qui sont pas forcément les
moments où on produit et puis encore une
fois on a besoin d'électricité on a
besoin de gaz vert on a besoin de réseau
de chaleur enfin on a besoin d'un d'un
équilibre global des sources d'énergie
sur la CSPE
on va donc délibérer le 13 juillet
refaire une analyse donc une hypothèse
sur la contribution des ENR
aux charges de service public
contribution positive elle sera pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'on avait calculé en
novembre puisque on l'a calculé en
novembre avec les prix de marché qu'on a
dû prendre les prix de septembre quand
on a fait notre délibération en novembre
les prix ont été divisés plus que par
deux donc on va être dans ce type de
facteur on va être dans l'équivalent
d'une division par deux de notre
précédente hypothèse j'ai pas le chiffre
définitif parce que il n'est pas fini et
la délibération et la semaine prochaine
mais en ordre de grandeur voilà on sera
on va diviser en gros par deux notes
notre hypothèse précédente
monsieur sénateur Chauvet pour
l'application de la loi accélération des
ENR la creux était favorable
aux différentes évolutions de ses
compétences donc on va essayer d'y
répondre au mieux
avec évidemment des ETP qui sont limités
et donc toujours la même question de
savoir comment on fait plus avec pas
plus de personnes et pas plus d'agents
mais ça c'est la question récurrente
c'est très important de réussir à
intégrer dans les appels d'offres le
bilan carbone d'un côté et la
contribution territoriale de l'autre on
a besoin dans les appels d'offres de
pouvoir favoriser un écosystème français
et européen les Américains le font
massivement avec la here il y a vraiment
pas de raison que on soit la seule zone
de développement qui n'essaye pas de
développer de maintenir des filières
industrielles qui sont absolument
stratégiques pour l'instant on est très
limité par ces critères et si on a la
possibilité d'avoir une rédaction de ces
critères plus ouverte et plus
opérationnelle et donc que ce soit des
critères qui puissent jouer on très
content sur la mutualisation du
raccordement on y travaille énormément
avec
enedis et RTE à la fois pour anticiper
les travaux de raccordement quand c'est
possible on l'a fait à Dunkerque et puis
pour gérer avec eux la manière dont la
file d'attente va pouvoir être
éventuellement modifié
dans les zones dans lesquelles les
demandes sont trop importantes pour
faire en sorte que on prenne dans la
file d'attente des projets dont la
maturité est sûr et donc on ne bloque
pas du raccordement de la puissance de
raccordement pour des projets qui en
fait ne se réaliseraient pas c'est en
particulier le cas dans la zone fausse
Marseille
où j'étais d'ailleurs hier et avant-hier
où les besoins de raccordement sont
immenses parce qu'on a énormément de
projets industriels de tes carbonation
qui attendent
sur la surveillance des contrats long
terme on le souhaite parce que pour que
enfin nous on est absolument convaincu
qu'on a besoin de contrats long terme
sur le marché qu'il faut que c'est
contrastes se développe et on a besoin
d'avoir une visibilité sur les
conditions contractuelles à la fois les
prix et les conditions ne serait-ce que
pour ajuster la partie appel d'offres à
la réalité de cette partie là du marché
donc on avait souhaité être pouvoir être
mobilisé et donc du coup pouvoir faire
un rapport d'évaluation sur ce sujet
vous nous avez donné partiellement la
compétence je dis partiellement parce
qu'on voulait avoir la possibilité de
demander à tout ceux qui signent des PPA
donc à tous les fournisseurs de nos
fournir les informations pas seulement
qu'on sait aussi sur des installations
qui sont en partie régulées ça n'a pas
été retenu dans la version définitive de
la loi après on considère que nos
pouvoirs de police généraux nous
permettent de le faire puis on verra
bien si les fournisseurs refusent ou pas
sur l'autoconsommation on s'est
également un sujet qu'on va reprendre il
faut qu'on arrive à développer
l'autoconsommation dans des conditions
qui permettent toujours la solidarité
nationale sur les réseaux donc c'est
l'enjeu sur la reine sur le CP1 et CP2
en fait je partage assez votre assez
largement votre analyse alors d'abord on
n'a pas pu vous propositions madame la
sénatrice monsieur sénateur parce que
vous avez adopté le rapport et donc vos
propositions on les découvrira quand le
rapport sera rendu public et on les lira
avec beaucoup d'intérêts donc je les
écoute
ça y est peut-être depuis 10 minutes
mais
voilà mais du coup on les avait pas eu
avant donc
du coup on les analysera dès qu'on les
aura et j'espère que Fabien ne sera pas
ses propos sur le sur le CPA
oui finalement alors le CP1 il va des
fournisseurs qui avaient trop demandé
vers les fournisseurs qui avaient
proportionnellement moins demandé donc
il va des fournisseurs qui avaient
exagéré leur demande au fournisseur qui
avait une demande plus mesurée
moi je partage votre point de vue sur le
fait que infini les CPA devraient
retourner aux consommateurs et
d'ailleurs on l'a écrit dans la
libération sur les CPA t'assure sur les
CPA 1 et 2
quand il s'agit de consommateur en
dehors des mécanismes de tarifs
réglementés et de boucliers nous avons
invité les fournisseurs à restituer cet
argent en consommateur on n'a pas pu
faire plus parce qu'on n'a pas les
éléments légaux pour le faire donc on
n'a pas de base légale pour aller
au-delà de ça mais dans une période dans
lesquelles les prix ont énormément
augmenté et où certains fournisseurs
infinis récupère de l'argent ça serait
normal et donc que je le redis on
souhaite vraiment que les fournisseurs
rendent à leurs clients en fonction des
conditions contractuelles et en fonction
de leur situation
la quote-part du CP1 que les
fournisseurs qui avaient moins demandé
ont reçu
et bah très bien pour les consommateurs
qui sont protégés par le bouclier du
coup eux ils n'ont pas été pénalisés par
le fait que les traitements étaient
finalement un petit peu plus élevé que
ce qu'il aurait dû
et c'est en fait au budget de l'État
qu'il faudrait rendre il y a pas de
mécanisme qui permet de le faire dans
les textes actuels sur le bouclier 2023
c'est on a plus de marge de manœuvre
puisque le bouclier 2023 prévoit que des
fournisseurs sont compensés dans la
limite de leur coût d'approvisionnement
et on pouvait considérer que quand il
récupère du CP1 ça fait baisser leur
coût d'approvisionnement c'est de la
mécanique un peu complexe chez nous mais
on pourrait considérer qu'on saurait
faire ça sur le bouclier 2023 mais en
tout cas en fait les textes avaient pas
été conçus dans une période où il y
avait autant de CP1 et l'analyse de la
Creuse c'est vraiment que c'était
difficile à prévoir c'est-à-dire qu'on a
5,6% de CP1 fin de sur demande dans une
période où la consommation à infinie
baissée de 4% et c'était pas prévu et où
les fournisseurs alternatifs ont
massivement perdu des clients
je vous rappelle que le guichet à Rennes
a eu lieu avant la corrosion sous
contrainte il a eu lieu avant la
déclaration de guerre de la Russie sur
l'Ukraine donc il a eu lieu un moment où
c'était pas évident de prévoir qu'on
aurait une baisse de consommation et une
répartition de marché de ce type mais en
tout cas oui à un moment le CPA si le
système était maintenu aurait vocation à
retourner vers les consommateurs sur
l'abus d'arène on mobilise tous les
outils qu'on a donc on a requalifié des
demandes d'arènes au guichet 2023
envoyer trois fournisseurs au cordis en
demandant une suspension des livraisons
d'arènes courants 2023 grâce
[Musique]
aux nouvelles compétences que vous nous
avez donné dans la dernière loi de
finances on a trois enquêtes en cours un
PV et chez le fournisseur pour
contradiction et j'ai déjà fait un
article 40 le deuxième PV je le signe la
semaine prochaine et le troisième dès
que possible ensuite tout ça va au
cordis et on a des enquêtes de gsccrf en
cours donc on est vraiment en train de
mobiliser tous les outils qu'on a pour
lutter contre les abus d'arènes après la
question sous-jacente c'est la
saisonnalité des droits d'arènes versus
l'utilisation la reine est un mécanisme
qui va durer encore deux exercices
puisqu'il a vocation à être remplacée
si la reine était pérenne il faudrait
vraiment se reposer cette question là
après je rappelle que ça a été conçu
comme ça pour privilégier les
industriels dans les droits à Rennes
c'est-à-dire pour privilégier les gros
consommateurs au détriment si je peux
dire des consommateurs particuliers donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y a un
déséquilibre entre la période qui génère
des droits et la période d'utilisation
c'était l'idée d'essayer de donner
proportionnellement un peu plus de
droits aux gros consommateurs industriel
et un petit peu moins aux consommateurs
individuels mais en tout cas on mobilise
tous les outils qu'on a et pour répondre
à Dominique Estrosi Sassone on est
demandeur de récupérer des autorisations
de fourniture et demandeurs de durcir
les textes et si ça se produit on le
fera avec vigilance et rigueur parce que
il faut durcir les obligations
potentielles sur les fournisseurs et il
faut revoir les autorisations de
fourniture à intervalles réguliers la
fourniture d'électricité ou de gaz
sais pas exactement la fourniture de
n'importe quel produit et donc il faut
être sûr que le fournisseur qui fait ça
et en capacité de le faire et on voit
des fournisseurs qui commencent qui
arrêtent qui repassent des portefeuilles
clients à d'autres filiales qui émergent
enfin vous avez dû les voir aussi on
essaye de lutter avec les moyens qu'on a
dans ces situations là
sur
l'amélioration de la protection des
consommateurs et de l'information des
consommateurs je pense que c'est un
sujet qu'on regardera avec intérêt aussi
notamment sur les modifications
contractuelles c'est des sujets dont on
discute avec la DGCCRF pour voir comment
parce que elle aussi elle peut être
active sur la protection des
consommateurs
moi je serais à première vue favorable
même si j'ai pas encore lu les
propositions à ce qu'on renforce le code
de la consommation c'est vrai que les
consommateurs ont pas l'habitude de
regarder de près leur contrats ni
d'électricité ni de gaz contrairement à
leur contrat de téléphonie et de boxe et
du coup
le simple fait de savoir que votre
contrat est à prix variable et pas du
tout une évidence une grande partie des
contrats sont en fait à prix variables
indexées les modes d'indexation sont mal
connues et les conditions dans
lesquelles les conditions contractuelles
peuvent changer sont également très mal
connues donc on a beaucoup
d'informations à faire du consommateur
sur comment choisir un contrat et
renforcer les obligations sur le fait
qu'on modifie pas unilatéralement pas
avec des délais trop court etc me paraît
me paraît tout à fait une bonne idée
bien tu peux tout commander maintenant
aux autres
commissaires de voilà d'être bien concis
dans leur question Franck montoger
ensuite pierregot
merci madame la Présidente
la creux merci pour votre présentation
également votre travail en tant que
présidente j'aurai trois petits sujets
[Musique]
quels enseignements le cas échéant
tirez-vous pour votre mission de
fonction de contrôle des déficiences de
la creux en matière de contrôle des
fournisseurs alternatifs en tout cas de
certains qui ont bénéficié de la reine
voilà des sanctions ont été prises très
tardivement
et on sait par ailleurs que la plupart
des des bénéficiaires de la reine en
tant que fournisseur n'ont pas par
exemple été ou contribué à la production
voilà première question Quel est quel
est votre contribution en termes de
proposition
et d'échanges avec les autres autorités
de contrôle européenne
en matière de mix de market design
pardon voilà nous français on a intérêt
à ce que les prix se forment au plus
près des composantes diverses de notre
mix énergétique national
comment si c'est le cas ou quels sont
vos propositions en rapport avec avec ce
sujet et dernière question si c'est dans
vos compétences je ne suis pas certain
qu'elle analyse ou évaluation
faites-vous à ce stade de la mise à
droite de la loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables alors elle est
récente les choses sont en train plus ou
moins bien de se mettre en place sur les
sur les territoires et je pense qu'il
faut pas louper le début voilà donc ce
que là aussi vous avez un regard et
éventuellement des propositions pour que
les choses se passent au mieux et le
plus rapidement possible merci
on encourage le développement des pompes
à chaleur ce qui est logique dans le
même temps on exige de supprimer les
chaudières à gaz alors qu'on ne fait
toujours pas quand la production
d'électricité sera suffisante pour
répondre à toutes les demandes et on ne
sait pas non plus si les réseaux seront
adaptés est-ce qu'il ne serait pas sage
de garder en secours des chaudières à
gaz au moment où on tiendra plus le
réseau électrique
excellente question merci Pierre Serge
méryou Jean-Jacques Michaud ensuite
merci madame la Présidente ma question
reprend un petit peu celle de Pierre
lourd et notamment ce que vous avez
évoqué en début l'inquiétude sur
l'augmentation de consommation
d'électricité et les investissements qui
qui vont avec alors les investissements
pour la production d'électricité le
nucléaire les énergies les EnR et d'une
part et les réseaux qui sont aussi un
point
fragile et sensible en ce qui concerne
l'électricité donc ma question c'est de
savoir si on a si on est serein par
rapport à cette augmentation dans la
capacité de production et transport et
quel sera l'impact prévisible sur
l'augmentation du coût de l'électricité
dont on sait qu'en France il est quand
même plutôt abordable et qui constitue
un atout pour l'activité industrielle ça
c'est ma première question sur la
deuxième question ça concerne ça
concerne la reine et est-ce que vous
souhaitez ou est-ce que vous envisagez
parce que si j'ai bien compris la loi ne
vous donne pas toutes les possibilités
de contrôle sur sur la reine donc est-ce
que vous souhaitez que la législation
évolue pour que le contrôle de la reine
soit beaucoup plus stricte
et notamment est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
que les producteurs alternent à des
producteurs alternatifs soient
réellement obligé de construire des
capacités de production ou à participer
financièrement au programme
d'investissement des industriels je
pense notamment à EDF qui sont qui
produisent eux et qui investissent pour
produire de l'énergie électrique voilà
merci Jean-Jacques
Michaud ensuite
madame la Présidente un jour trois
petites questions la première concernant
les Jean-Jacques Michaud sénateurs de
l'Ariège excusez-moi
la première question c'est par rapport à
tous les objectifs que vous avez assigné
à la creux est-ce que les moyens que
vous avez votre organisme seront
suffisants pour pour les assumer la
deuxième c'est pour revenir sur le
rapport que nous avons voté tout à
l'heure par rapport à la reine
je sais pas si c'est trop péjoratif mais
il me semble qu'il y a un fatra
d'organisme qui s'occupe de la
distribution à part entre EDF rde
vous-même la Caisse des dépôts ou est-ce
qu'il y aurait pas une simplification
pour une mais au moins pour une
meilleure lisibilité
des sommes qui sont en jeu et la
troisième question mais vous avez déjà
un petit peu répondu je vais aller très
vite dans votre dans votre premier
propos liminaires vous parliez des
enjeux du développement des EnR et du
nucléaire est-ce qu'il y a une
hiérarchie dedans parce qu'il me semble
que dans le mythe énergétique et Daniel
grimiller le disait on a besoin d'une
offre d'électricité de base et si c'est
les EnR qui sont la base est-ce qu'on
arrivera à financer le nucléaire
derrière voilà
merci ensuite Olivier Ritman merci
madame la présidente madame la
Présidente deux questions rapides
concernant la souveraineté et la
sobriété en ce moment où la guerre en
Ukraine est sur notre cantina
assez rapidement une Union européenne de
l'énergie et ma deuxième question porte
sur les perspectives d'inflation en
matière d'évolution des tarifs pour nos
collectivités locales des régies et des
délégations de service public est-ce que
vous avez une lisibilité
merci beaucoup Bernard Olivier Rickman
ensuite Christian Redon sarrazzi oui
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente Olivier Ritman sénateur de la
Haute-Saône je vais vous parler des
réseaux mais notamment des réseaux sur
les petits territoires ruraux notamment
mon département la Haute-Saône qui avait
jusqu'à maintenant des réseaux adaptés à
la fois à la population mais à la fois
notre capacité de production très
limitée puisqu'on n'avait pas
nidraulique ni fossile ni nucléaire
aucune production d'électricité une
petite population or il se trouve qu'au
niveau des RNR on a un potentiel assez
important je prends un exemple sur le
gaz la Haute-Saône sera avant tout le
monde à 50% de production de gaz Var gaz
vert pardon dans les deux ans qui
viennent notamment duo-métanisa et on a
une capacité un potentiel de
développement sur les énergies
renouvelables au niveau électrique très
important j'ai emmené une partie de la
commission à faire économique visiter la
semaine dernière la première canopée
agrivoltaïque sur grande culture au
monde installée en Haute-Saône sur trois
hectares je vous invite à venir la
visiter si ça vous dit c'est un modèle
assez exceptionnel par contre on a ce
qui dit ressorti des opérateurs qui
étaient avec nous producteurs etc c'est
que on a une capacité de production
d'énergie notamment photovoltaïques ou
méthanisation très importante mais nos
réseaux sont complètement saturés dans
les 10 ans qui viennent et aujourd'hui
pouvoir transporter cette électricité
par des raccordements coûte très très
cher et donc stop carrément tous les
projets qui peuvent être mis en place
alors y a-t-il dans vos projets
je comprends qu'il y a des gros
accompagnements sur des projets
importants mais sur les petits
territoires ruraux sur lesquels ça peut
représenter un potentiel de
développement très important avaient une
véritable volonté d'accompagnement sur
les réseaux et d'argent mis sur les
réseaux de développement des réseaux sur
nos petits territoires ruraux merci
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
madame la Présidente pour
vos propos
je reviendrai rapidement sur la fin du
tarif réglementé sur le gaz et en
particulier la conséquence pour les
collectivités territoriales qui sont
pour de nombre dentelles très
dépendantes et avec des difficultés pour
évoluer vers d'autres sources
d'énergie collectivités aussi aux autres
organismes HLM etc enfin le logement
collectif donc elles sont actuellement
dans les difficultés budgétaires
majeures qui sont très inquiétantes pour
les pour les exercices à venir qu'est-ce
que vous prévoyez comme accompagnement
pour éviter que ce poste là ne grève la
capacité d'action des de nombreuses
collectivités
merci Madame la présente une petite
question rapide sur la première
ENR pilotable en France qui est le bois
énergie qui représente entre 36 et 40 %
je crois c'est mes derniers chiffres
dans production de NR et un équivalent
de 225 terawatt-heure donc je voudrais
savoir quelle est voilà quel est votre
stratégie s'agissant de la le nr bois et
notamment comme ça a été évoqué de
soutien de besoins de soutien de
financement notamment au réseau
lié au chaufferie biomasse bois dans les
territoires
merci Anne Catherine et Daniel salmon
merci madame la Présidente merci pour
cette présentation bon je vais essayer
de pas être don dans on sait que les 10
à 15 ans à venir vont être difficiles
questions équilibrage du réseau
électrique et le remplacement de toutes
les chaudières à gaz par des packs
amènerait une pointe de 20 GW ce qui est
complètement impossible à tenir donc
voilà je voudrais avoir à nouveau votre
position sur ce sur ce sujet des
chaudières à gaz et également la
question des réseaux elle a déjà été
évoqué mais les fondamentale j'ai visité
lundi dernier à rebours un rebours de
gaz aujourd'hui on est en train inverser
effectivement de production très
centralisée on voit avec des productions
très diffuses donc la question des
réseaux est complètement entière et donc
il y a un vrai sujet d'investissement à
ce niveau là et juste dernière chose
vous avez parlé de l'effacement
effectivement c'est que ça va être
crucial dans les années à venir il y a
une vieille archéisation à faire
pouvez-vous nous en dire un petit peu
plus et quels sont les contrats qui sont
mis en place à ce niveau là merci
très bien merci mes chers collègues j'ai
une dernière petite question madame la
Présidente mais qui est très technique
que nous avons vu d'ailleurs en
Haute-Saône vous savez que les
producteurs qui ont des méthaniseurs en
particulier
ont des contrats sur un certain niveau
de production
pendant cette crise de l'électricité ou
le prix de l'électricité à augmenter ils
étaient obligés d'aller sur le marché
acheter très cher de l'énergie remettant
en remettant en considération
l'équilibre budgétaire de leur
production de méthaniseur ils ont
demandé en fait la possibilité de faire
de l'autoconsommation et de passer au
dessus de leur niveau de contrat sur la
partie qui leur sert à produire en fait
pour eux-mêmes ce n'est pas possible
est-ce qu'on peut au niveau de la crue
regardez ce sujet avec intérêt parce
qu'il me semble qu'il n'est pas dénué
quand même de de bon sens voilà
merci madame la Présidente je vais
essayer de répondre à toutes ces
questions
monsieur le sénateur montoget vis-à-vis
des fournisseurs alternatifs
en fait
le système qui a été construit a été
construit dans une dans une période dans
laquelle
les besoins d'investissement existaient
mais étaient moins forts et surtout la
crise des prix et l'évolution des prix
étaient pas du tout celle qu'on a connu
pour moi les grands éléments de
modification du système pour la suite
c'est
plus de rigueur sur les fournisseurs
alternatifs avec des autorisations de
fourniture revue et rendus un petit peu
plus stricte et des obligations
prudentielles sous une forme qu'il faut
encore définir qui n'est pas tout à fait
mûr mais dans laquelle on incite les
fournisseurs alternatifs à
s'approvisionner en partie à long terme
quel que soit le type d'obligation qu'on
met en place si on fait ça ça les incite
soit à s'intégrer avec de la production
en amont soit de contractualiser à moyen
long terme avec de la production en
amont c'est-à-dire soit il produisent
eux-mêmes soit ils sont trop petits pour
le faire mais ils contractualise avec
des producteurs et ces bénéfiques pour
tout le monde c'est bénéfiques pour les
producteurs qui ont un débouché à long
terme c'est bénéfique pour les
consommateurs des fournisseurs
alternatifs qui parce que la fourniture
est adossée à de la production qui
elle-même est verrouillée d'une certaine
manière à long terme donc pour moi c'est
vraiment vers ça qu'il faut aller et
après le mécanisme de l'arène lui-même
parce qu'il est asymétrique parce que
les ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure la
période de constitution des droits n'est
pas la même que la période d'utilisation
des droits
créent des difficultés et
les outils juridiques se sont renforcés
c'est juste long moi j'ai lancé les
enquêtes les premières enquêtes en
septembre
mais simplement il faut un agent
enquêteur qui fait que ça qui
enquête qui enquête par écrit qui
récupère des réponses qui les analysent
qui ensuite fait son procès-verbal qui
constate qu'il y a des manquements
procès-verbal qui part à la
contradiction ensuite ça va partir au
cordis ce qui va réinstruire et tout ça
va être très long
on a sur le métier avec le cordiste donc
et la formation de jugement de la creux
mais qui est autonome par rapport au
collège dans le président est Thierry
tuot tout un travail qui est en train
d'aboutir sur des propositions qui vont
être législatives pour simplifier et
accélérer les sanctions parce que là on
instruit trois fois en fait et donc
c'est pas c'est pas très efficient c'est
législatif donc
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
il faudra qu'on trouve un vecteur
législatif pour faire ça ça pourrait
éventuellement être la loi de
transposition de la réforme du marché
européen de l'énergie ou un autre texte
mais on en a besoin nous on est bloqué
par ça et alors même qu'on
au bout de procédure qui sont longues on
a les éléments pour constater des abus
donc la prochaine modification c'est la
modification des procédures et là on
pourrait gagner énormément de temps si
on faisait différemment
sur le Market design donc l'organisation
du marché
si on a dose vraiment à
si on ados les obligations des
fournisseurs à de l'approvisionnement
long terme on rapprochera les prix de
marché des prix du de des outils de
production sur sol français donc du mix
national puisque les fournisseurs iront
conclure des contrats à long terme et
les interconnexions étant limitées nous
on souhaite aussi qu'il puisse y avoir
des contrats long terme conclus sur les
interconnexions ce qui n'est pas
possible mais ça veut dire qu'ils iront
forcément aller chercher de
l'électricité là où elle est produite et
donc ça rapprochera le prix final du
prix long terme si je pense c'est un
objectif et pour votre dernière question
sur l'application de la loi
d'accélération des renouvelables c'est
encore un peu tôt on a une partie qui
est chez nous sur laquelle on travaille
après l'important c'est vraiment d'aller
faire les schémas territoriaux les zones
d'accélération territoriales
pour qu'on ait à la fois les zones dans
lesquelles c'est difficile mais les
zones dans lesquelles c'est faisable
parce que si on a finalement que des
zones dans lesquelles c'est difficile on
n'arrivera pas à boucler l'équation
on est concerné en deuxième niveau parce
qu'on fait les schémas de raccordement
des ENR on n'est pas parti prenante à la
discussion locale et c'est normal
puisque la crue essentiellement un
organisme national même si moi je
commence à passer pas mal de temps en
visite de terrain parce que je pense que
c'est utile d'aller à la rencontre des
élus et des producteurs localement
mais on est concerné sur les schémas de
raccordement qui eux-mêmes
doivent être cohérents avec les zones
d'accélération donc on est enfin il faut
les faire ensemble c'est-à-dire on peut
pas faire des schémas de raccordement
avant de savoir où on va mettre les EnR
mais dès qu'on sait où on va mettre les
EnR il faut faire les schémas de
raccordement qui permettent de le faire
donc en tout cas oui on a un exercice
dans lequel on est on est également
concerné
sur les pompes à chaleur et les
chaudière gaz voilà ma position est
vraiment une position de prudence c'est
à dire il faut des carboner le chauffage
c'est sûr
j'ai d'ailleurs porté dans mes fonctions
antérieures la fin des chaudières fuel
qui a été un sujet difficile et délicat
à mettre en oeuvre chaudière gaz on
n'est pas dans le même volume le rapport
qu'on a fait sur les infrastructures
montre que dans les hypothèses les pires
c'est-à-dire si on ne faisait pas assez
de rénovation on pourrait aller jusqu'à
une pointe supplémentaire de 35
gigawatts qui serait pas du tout
accepter acceptable pour pour le réseau
électrique donc il faut simplement
réussir à
à faire monter en puissance de réseau
électrique à la bonne vitesse par
rapport à l'évolution des chaudières gaz
ce qui pourrait mener plutôt dans un
premier temps à mon avis à une fin des
aides avant d'aller à une interdiction
pure et simple parce que déjà si on
change le système d'aide et si on arrête
de subventionner les chaudières gaz on
passera un message clair et en tout cas
ça ne peut se faire que de façon
coordonnée avec l'évolution de la
capacité électrique et l'évolution des
réseaux sinon on va pas y arriver
probablement qu'il faut aussi se poser
la question des pompes à chaleur
classiques ou des pompes à chaleur
hybrides qui permettent d'aller chercher
du gaz soit quand il fait vraiment très
froid et qu'elle marche moins bien soit
quand on est vraiment trop tendus en
électricité qu'on a besoin du gaz en
tout cas dans la crise précédente on a
bien vu que la complémentarité des
réseaux c'était quand même utile
sur la consommation d'électricité ce qui
est sur les investissements en
production en réseau est-ce qu'on est
serein c'est monsieur le sénateur
merillou qui me posait la question
sur la zone n'est pas totalement serein
parce qu'on a un énorme pic
d'investissement à passer c'est à la
fois un sujet de financement un sujet de
faisabilité opérationnelle ces
discussions qu'on a au quotidien avec
enedis et avec RTE
sur leur capacité aussi à
s'approvisionner il faut acheter des
portes des postes sources il faut
acheter des câbles pour les équipements
et sur leur capacité à avoir leur propre
compétences et les compétences des
entreprises de sous-traitantes et
partenaires pour le faire
et la trajectoire d'investissement est
élevée ce qui veut dire que toute chose
égale par ailleurs ça va renchérir un
peu ou beaucoup les tarifs d'utilisation
des réseaux ce qui va être un énorme
sujet pour la campagne tarifaire qui
arrive donc on est déterminé c'est
le chemin existe il est possible il est
pas facile à tenir on a 40 gigas watts
de puissance de l'éolien offshore à
raccorder ce qu'il a aussi va être
extrêmement important et pas du tout
comparable à ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
présent RTE a été au rendez-vous des
raccordements sur le lien offshore je
voudrais le saluer mais en fait le
volume de raccordement est énorme et
peut-être pour rebondir tout de suite
sur votre question monsieur le sénateur
on est très conscient du fait qu'il y a
les raccordements les gros les moyens et
les petits en fait pour simplifier on
passe d'un système qui était un système
simple cartésien centralisé et
descendant on avait 56 EPR qui
produisaient l'essentiel et puis après
on avait un maillage qui ramenait
jusqu'au consommateur final en gaz en
gros produisait pas on importait et donc
on avait des flux d'un port et puis tout
le réseau de gaz était fait pour
descendre ses flux d'infos d'un port
jusqu'au consommateur final un système
qui doit être maillé complètement
différemment avec de la production un
peu partout et puis directionnel alors
en gaz c'est une révolution de
culturelle chez gr TF qui sont en train
de faire ils sont extrêmement mobilisés
là-dessus c'est le cœur de leurs projets
stratégique ils sont devenus ils sont
pas devenus producteurs mais ils
acceptent du gaz sur le réseau alors
qu'avant c'était pas du tout le cas par
exemple les odorisent ils autorisaient
jamais avant ils s'étaient jamais posé
la question de l'autorisation ils sont
maintenant ils ont des clients qui sont
en fait des producteurs leurs clients
avant n’étaient que des clients
consommateurs donc c'est un changement
complète culture et ils sont en train de
le faire je voudrais saluer la
motivation des équipes de GrDF là-dessus
nous ça nous oblige à valider des
investissements qui sont des
investissements de renforcement de
maillage et de rebours
on est très vigilant là dessus et pour
vous donner un exemple on valide des
libération par délibérations des
investissements quand on y les propose
en général ils ont propose une vingtaine
ou une trentaine on valide ça tous les
trimestres à peu près on s'est mis
d'accord que maintenant si nous présente
20 investissements et qu'on en valide 18
on va passer toute la séance de la
commission sur les deux qu'on valide pas
c'est-à-dire on va considérer que les 18
c'est très bien et que si les services
nous disent il y en a deux qu'on veut
pas prendre le collège challenge les
services pour dire vous êtes sûr que
vous voulez pas les prendre pourquoi
vous voulez pas les prendre qu'est-ce
que vous attendez pour les prendre
est-ce que ça coûte trop cher est-ce que
c'est pas le bon dimensionnement etc et
si vous les prenez pas cette fois-ci
est-ce qu'on est d'accord que vous
revenez dans trois mois en nous disant
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
répondre aux besoins si c'est pas la
solution proposée donc on est vraiment
dans cette optique là pour accompagner
le développement de ces réseaux et c'est
vrai en gaz et c'est vrai aussi en
électricité après il y a des endroits
dans lesquels le réseau a pas du tout
été fait pour supporter autant de trafic
en électricité en particulier parce
qu'il y a peu d'habitants donc il y a
peu de ma électrique peu d'habitants
également beaucoup de NR possibles et
égal
transformation du réseau à faire vite
nous on suit avec enedis les délais de
raccordement c'est un sujet sur lequel
on n'est pas totalement d'accord avec
enedis parce que
enedis regarde toute la chaîne de délai
de raccordement et considère qu'elle
s'améliore nous on regarde la chaîne qui
est vraiment sous responsabilité enedis
et on considère qu'elle s'améliore mais
pas assez vite donc voilà on a des
discussions sur les indicateurs c'est
pareil chez nadis ils sont extrêmement
conscients de ça mais on a des
investissements qu'on n'avait jamais
fait pour des process qu'on n'avait pas
fait pour des sens de circulation qu'on
avait pas fait et donc on a une
révolution des réseaux à faire autant
que une révolution de la production et
on sera peut-être pas totalement mais
mobiliser oui sur la reine je pense que
j'ai assez largement répondu sur est-ce
qu'on a assez de d'effectifs pour faire
ça bah pas tout à fait pour être honnête
donc notre budget a discuté chaque année
en un 160 personnes qui travaillent pour
la cruche je voudrais en profiter de
nouveau pour saluer leur motivation leur
engagement et leur professionnalisme on
récupère assez régulièrement plein de
nouvelles missions et c'est bien parce
que c'est cohérent avec notre
portefeuille de mission on souhaite
aussi voilà être acteur sur l'hydrogène
sur la capture du CO2 mais c'est tendu
on a on a beaucoup de missions très
diverses donc ce sont des petites
équipes sujets par sujet ça va être deux
trois chargés de mission quatre chargés
de mission donc c'est tendu c'est
beaucoup de boulot et du coup on
reviendra probablement avec une petite
demande complémentaire c'est pas des
volumes très importants mais si vous
nous le proposez on le fera sûrement
sur les circuits à Rennes caisse de
dépôts en fait les calculs sont faits
chez nous donc on fait tous les calculs
avec justement une petite équipe et
ensuite c'est la caisse qui paye
laquelle la caisse et l'opérateur qui
qui est l'acteur financier des droits à
Rennes je pense pas qu'on est de
difficultés particulières avec ça et RTE
n'est pas dans les circuits et EDF non
plus EDF reçoit les CP2 à la fin mais
c'est tout Dominique je sais pas si tu
veux préciser un petit point
RTE c'est lui qui fournit les données de
consommation puisque là en fait on
rejoue complètement toute l'année 2022
de meilleur par demi-heure pour
l'ensemble des clients français et d'où
le fait que ça arrive un peu tard je je
disais que les acteurs n'avaient pas
d'information c'est normal c'est que
tous ces calculs doivent être fait donc
là en tant que fournisseur de l'ensemble
des données de consommation sur le
territoire national
et sur la hiérarchie nerf nucléaire je
pense qu'il y a un point ce que j'ai pas
cité dans mon propos en productif mais
sur lequel je voudrais revenir je
regarde l'heure parce que terega va nous
attendre mais c'est pas grave
c'est pas la même temporalité c'est à
dire le nucléaire le nouveau nucléaire
tel qu'il est lancé il est lancé
maintenant les mécanismes de financement
sont en train d'être étudiés pour
ensuite qu'une décision puisse être
prise pour savoir comment on finance le
nouveau nucléaire et les prochains
réacteurs nouveaux nucléaires arrivent
autour de 2035 dans une hypothèse
favorable d'ici là on a un pic de besoin
électrique qui est majeur et donc ce qui
peut y répondre ce sont les
renouvelables donc il faut vraiment pas
opposer les deux et parce qu'on peut pas
se dire si on relance suffisamment de
nucléaire on a plus finalement besoin de
nouveaux renouvelables on a vraiment
besoin des deux et donc et notamment
dans la temporalité on a besoin du
renouvelable le offshore mais pas que
dans les 10 prochaines années et quand
le nouveau parc nucléaire arrivera c'est
aussi le moment où une partie des
réacteurs actuels sera prolongée jusqu'à
60 ans ou pas
à ce moment là on aura peut-être un
petit peu plus de flexibilité de marge
de manœuvre sur le choix sur le parc
mais pour l'instant c'est les EnR toute
NR confondues qui nous permettent de
passer le pic à venir qui est
extrêmement important pour 2030 2035
monsieur le sénateur bu votre question
sur l'Union européenne de l'énergie est
très ouverte donc
sa mériterait une audition à part
entière pour l'instant les choix c'est
un marché unifié et un mix énergétique
qui reste sous compétences nationales
pour moi c'est important que le mix
énergétique reste sous compétences
nationales mais donc une Union
européenne de l'énergie sinon ça
pourrait probablement aller un cran plus
loin sur l'inflation
les prix de la molécule enfin des
électrons enfin de l'électricité
elle-même ou du gaz ont baissé mais le
gars c'est vraiment revenu à niveau
assez bas l'électricité c'est revenu à
un niveau intermédiaire avec une prime
de risque et pas complètement
négligeable encore entre l'Allemagne et
la France après les tarifs de réseaux
vont finir par peser un peu c'est à dire
ce qu'on se dit là sur les enjeux sur
les réseaux vont finir par peser de
façon non négligeable sur les tarifs
finaux sénateur Hitman je crois que j'ai
répondu sur la fin des trdg
on a par ailleurs fait une offre de
service aux organismes HLM et aux
collectivités territoriales donc pour
les organismes HLM avec l'USH on
travaille à un guide pratique et un
appui à la contractualisation on sort ce
guide pratique je crois fin juillet donc
on a une coopération vraiment rapprochée
avec le monde du parc social pour aider
les organismes que ce soit des ESH ou
autres vous des OPH à contractualiser et
on a fait la même offre de service à la
MF pour voir si on pouvait travailler
avec les collectivités locales il faut
qu'on le fasse à d'autres associations
de collectivités pour voir si on peut
travailler au mode de contractualisation
pour aider en particulier les petites
collectivités à trouver comment
contractualiser
madame la sénatrice loisir sur le bois
énergie on n'est pas directement
compétent on n'a aucune compétence
directe en ce sujet après on est
compétent quand on voit la biomasse
arriver dans le mix énergétique en cause
génération ou sur de la production
électrique parce que le bois énergie
pour les réseaux de chaleur en
particulier c'est probablement vraiment
une solution
ça mène à la question de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on travaille de façon
transversale sur toutes les énergies à
l'échelle locale ce que nous on a une
vision forcément nationale et à
l'échelle locale c'est là où on remet en
cohérence les approvisionnements des
réseaux de chaleur les
approvisionnements engaz et en biogaz
les éventuelles développement locaux en
électricité et en bois énergie en tout
cas pour moi c'est une filière
indispensable dans la PPE
oui quand même un sujet co génération
notamment dans la même esprit que la
question de la présidente pour les
industries de la filière bois qui
peuvent ainsi produire leur propre
électricité et ça c'est un élément de
compétitivité de ces entreprises qui est
décisif aujourd'hui
bon bah c'est un point qu'on couvre
partiellement va parler tarifs et sur
lesquels on sera on sera vigilant pour
le sénateur seulement oui bah les 10 à
15 années difficiles sur les réseaux ça
c'est sûr que ils arrivent mais on
essaye de voilà d'accompagner ça au
mieux on a parlé des rebours sur les
phasements oui nous on a recommencé à
travailler sur tous les mécanismes de
flexibilité pour voir comment est-ce
qu'on les positionne on a aussi tout le
mécanisme de capacité qui peut jouer on
est il y a la production il y a les
réseaux et il y a la flexibilité au sens
large du terme et on a vraiment besoin
des trois donc on retravaille sur
l'effacement et pour madame la
Présidente sur les méthaniseurs il y a
eu beaucoup d'ajustements récents fait
pour essayer de de permettre le
dépassement du C-Max qui est la
consommation maximum plusieurs fois sur
une période de deux ans alors qu'avant
c'était un an et pour donner des
flexibilités de ce type donc le
ministère il travaille on y a travaillé
avec eux il y a un certain nombre de
décrets
et d'arrêter sur lesquels on a délibéré
récemment il me semble en donnant un
avis favorable on a effectivement besoin
de donner un peu de flexibilité au monde
de la méthanisation qui lui aussi
a été très frappée par les variations de
consommation et par les variations de
prix
11h44 mission accomplie madame la
Présidente je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir répondu de façon complète à
l'ensemble des questions de mes
collègues et puis voilà vous souhaitez
bonne continuation dans vos fonctions
voilà merci Madame pour la présidente et
vous souhaitez aussi de bonnes
continuations dans vos fonctions jusqu'à
la fin merci beaucoup